si on vous invite Laurent Berger c'est
parce que ce défilé du 1er mai sur fond
de réforme des retraites avait un goût
un peu particulier pour vous je pense
que la dans un an je serai un peu plus
loin où j'étais ailleurs mais je serai
toujours là toujours à mi-temps après 11
ans à la tête de la CFDT vous avez
choisi de passer la main
je suis heureux d'être là Marie lisez là
Marylise Léon c'est celle qui vous
succédera dans quelques semaines
Laurent Berger avec des parents en
cdtistes vous tombez très jeunes dans le
syndicalisme à 25 ans militant à la
Jeunesse ouvrière chrétienne vous
défendez déjà les jeunes apprentis et
leurs conditions de travail c'est votre
première télé on connaît beaucoup de
jeunes qui parlent après apprentissage
ont renonçait un apprentissage parce
qu'il faisait 45 heures chez un
employeur ils étaient pas payés ou alors
50 francs par-ci par là pour faire
plaisir
entrons-t-on vous avez gravi les
échelons à la CFDT jusqu'à en prendre la
tête en 2012 succédant à celui qui
restera votre mentor François cherrec je
suis content de la façon dont les choses
se sont passées avec avec Laurent une
transition qui se fait en douceur qui se
fait je dirais beaucoup de plaisir en
plus un poste que vous quitterez donc le
21 juin prochain on vous dit homme de
négociation quand votre monologue
CGTiste préfère l'action inflexible sur
le report de l'âge de départ en retraite
vous êtes devenu la clé de voûte de
l'Inter syndical des laissons ainsi
votre rôle de partenaire syndical pour
celui d'adversaires politiques car le
président de la République abo affirmait
devant les caméras c'est quelqu'un sous
différentes conditions avec qui moi j'ai
toujours très bien travaillé c'est pas
un désaccord sur un sujet qui vaut pour
toute une relation c'est quelqu'un pour
qui j'ai du respect aurais-je dire de
l'amitié
entrez manuel Macron et vous c'est peu
dire que la relation est tendue certains
dans la majorité présidentielle vous
prête des ambitions politiques une
partie de la gauche vous rêve même
candidat à la présidentielle mais ce
sera non point final répétez-vous
unlassablement alors Laurent Berger vous
qui terminez l'écriture d'un essai sur
le travail apparaître mi-mai si c'était
ça votre ambition politique que ce livre
soit la base d'un programme présidentiel
pour la gauche en 2027
réponse Laurent Berger dans ce livre
c'est un essai sur le travail à partir
de mon expérience de ce que j'ai pu voir
dans les nombreuses rencontres avec les
salariés et c'est j'espère une source
d'inspiration pour tous ceux qui pensent
que le travail est encore un élément
structurant aujourd'hui pour pour les
citoyens mais qu'il mérite d'être pensé
qu'il méritent d'être
reconnu que les travailleurs et
travailleuses ne sont pas une force
productive uniquement ce sont des des
moyens de travail
et moi mon rôle jusqu'à lors ça a été un
rôle syndical demain je disparais pas
disparaître je vais être plus discret
mais je veux continuer à travailler sur
ces enjeux du travail ces enjeux de la
démocratie et être utile en termes
d'idées et à ceux qui voudront bien les
saisir alors on va pas égrainer tout
l'album de vos onze années à la tête de
la CFDT mais quel est votre plus belle
victoire de quoi êtes-vous le plus fier
après ces 11 années est-ce que est-ce
que c'est ce moment que nous vivons et
cette unité syndicale dont vous vous
êtes un peu l'architecte aussi il y
aurait beaucoup à dire de ces 11 années
j'ai essayé des années traversées de
moments sociaux énormes il y a eu un
moment on a eu covid où il a fallu
maintenant une organisation syndicale
des propositions faire en sorte que
personne ne soit oublié dans les
protections qui ont été construites à ce
moment-là forcément on est devenu la
première organisation syndicale ça je
suis extrêmement fier on est une
organisation qui aujourd'hui dans ces
instances dirigeantes et à parité totale
et ça nous permet d'avoir une future
secrétaire général je suis très fier de
ça aussi je suis très fier oui cette
première place très fier de d'avoir
parcouru je crois à peu près tous les
départements français à la rencontre des
salariés et d'avoir obtenu quelques
belles victoires la complémentaire santé
pour les salariés du privé payer à 50%
par l'employeur l'extension de la
garantie jeune enfin je pourrais en
citer plein sans parler des combats
locaux
des échecs des échecs je crois que cette
fameuse négociation sur la modernisation
du dialogue social qu'on a sur laquelle
on n'arrive pas à aller au bout parce
que une vision du patronat et logique de
réduction du dialogue et du coup du
dialogue social et qui emmène le
lendemain enfin à quelques années après
les ordonnances les ordonnances travail
donc oui c'est traversé aussi de ça puis
c'est traversé le tristesse aussi la
disparition de François cherreg de mon
collègue Frédéric donc c'est une vie 10
ans c'est quand même un moment des
moments importants et donc c'est tout ça
qui fait ce syndicat aujourd'hui dans
cette bataille pas du tout on sait que
la CFDT réformiste avec cette culture du
compromis cette culture des équilibres
et du dialogue certains disent qu'elle
s'est un peu radicalisée je crois que il
faudrait regarder mais je crois que je
suis secrétaire général qui est assis et
plus d'accord interprofessionnels
durant ces 11 années presque j'ai
commencé des janvier 2013 un mois et
demi deux mois après secrétaire général
de la CFDT en signant l'accord soit
modernisation du travail
c'est la sécurité de l'emploi pardon
parce que rester 2008 c'est que l'emploi
avec de vraies avancées non et vous
savez je reste un adepte du dialogue
social je reste un adepte du compromis
mais le syndicalisme c'est porter une
critique sociale porter des propositions
et des revendications savoir s'engager
dans des négociations et des compromis
puis contester quand on n'est pas
d'accord il y a un truc qui n'aura pas
bougé chez moi c'est la version elle
nous injustices sociales c'est la
version inégalités et quand elles sont
là en conteste alors il y a le recul de
l'âge que vous avez toujours combattu et
aussi le président de la République avec
lequel vous n'avez pas eu des rapports
faciles et ce quasiment depuis le début
dès 2017 vous avez dit aux journalistes
du Monde Laurent Tello qui vous a
consacré un long portrait c'est
psychanalytique au bout d'un moment le
rapport qu'Emmanuel Macron a avec moi
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce rapport là
vous avez compris
conception qui est double un impensé de
sa part je crois sur ce qu'est la
démocratie sociale et le rôle du
syndicalisme qui ne se cantonne pas à
simplement l'entreprise mais qui a aussi
une vision globale soit sauter il y a
une deuxième c'est le rapport qu'on peut
avoir aux inégalités sociales au fait
que il y a dans notre pays comme partout
dans toute société des personnes qu'on
met qui mérite d'être accompagnées de
façon plus forte et que ça ne peut pas
être simplement être toi et la chance
t'aidera si son rapport au corps
intermédiaire change à l'avenir on sait
que c'est pas forcément sa tasse de thé
alors vous partez au moment où les
syndicats sont de retour en grâce plus
30 000 adhésion à la CFDT d'ailleurs
comme à la CGT un depuis
35000 depuis janvier dernier vous pensez
que c'est durable ce regain du
syndicalisme je crois que le
syndicalisme sort renforcé de cette
période même si on malheureusement on
regrette pour l'instant la promulgation
de cette loi mais je crois que c'est du
si on est capable de toujours parler à
hauteur de femmes et d'hommes des
réalités de travail et c'est la force de
la CFDT la CFDT a assumé une forme de de
leadership avec d'autres dans ce
mouvement dans ce mouvement social tout
simplement parce qu'on présente
l'épaisseur du monde du travail et y
compris ses professions dont on parlait
jamais jusqu'à lors et dont on parle
aujourd'hui parce qu'elles étaient là
pendant pendant le confinement et donc
oui ça peut être durable si on a une une
ambition c'est d'être utile être utile
au travailleur d'apporter des avancées
par des compromis par des résultats dans
l'entreprise jusqu'au niveau national
donc je suis je suis confiant je pars au
moment de la CFDT et la première
organisation syndicale est très en forme
un regain d'adhésion un regain de
création de sélection syndicale mais je
pars justement parce que on a des
pratiques démocratiques qui font qu'au
bout d'une dizaine d'années on part et
j'ai une éthique personnelle qui est que
je n'aime pas ma propriété les choses
collectives et qu'une organisation
syndicale c'est quelque chose de
collectif et que y compris la
personnalisation de ces derniers mois
c'était on va regarder une dernière
image avant de cet entretien les unes
les nombreuses une que vous avez fait
dans dans la presse tout ça ça va pas ça
va pas vous manquer est-ce qu'on l'a
cette image les voilà les interviews
trois médias par jour la lumière au fond
le fait que je vais vous dire tout à
l'heure même votre votre responsable de
la programmation quand elle est venue me
chercher Elise ça va vous manquer et de
toute façon assez spontanée je dis non
en fait je vais être très franc moi je
suis un produit du collectif de
l'éducation populaire je suis plutôt
timide et réservé et ce qui va me
manquer c'est le contact avec les
militants et les militantes je
l'exercerai j'espère d'une façon
différente mais oui non je sais ça fait
partie de la responsabilité j'ai
entretenu de bonnes relations
respectueuses avec l'ensemble des
journalistes parce que c'est ma façon
d'être mais voilà je vais passer à autre
chose et je vais voir plus de temps pour
lire plus de temps à consacrer au mien
et et à faire d'autres choses donc non
je voilà j'aime bien ces discussions je
veux pas cracher dans la soupe du tout
au contraire
et vous revenez avec le